bruno domaine 45 ans donc maire de
saint-leu depuis le 3 septembre 2010 est
vice président du tc au délégué à
l'aménagement du territoire et depuis le
28 juin de cette année vice président du
département délégué au tourisme et au
développement rural
je suis conseiller départementale sur le
canton xiv qui comprend la commune de
trois bassins en totalité et une partie
de sa le donc est l'hôte petite partie
est rattachée avec le canton 1 des
avirons étang salé donc je suis né à ça
le saint leusien depuis 1975 donc j'ai
grandi à ça le jeudi est ça le et
aujourd'hui
tout le monde rêve d'être maire ou
conseiller général sur l'ouest et
surtout sur ce canton la de saint paul
jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'étang salé puisqu'on a la cote
mais on a aussi
les eaux deux de ces deux villes là à
savoir prom à saint leu donc il ya un
attrait touristique économique vraiment
j'ai rêvé d'être conseiller
départemental là dessus je le suis
aujourd'hui et j'espère ne pas décevoir
les années street de saint leu et de
trois bassins
aujourd'hui au niveau de ma délégation
tourisme et développement rural c'est
vrai qu'on traverse une période
compliquée avec le co vide depuis deux
ans il ya eu avant ça la crise et les
jeunes aujourd'hui ça commence à
reprendre avec les gens sont vaccinés de
plus en plus à la réunion et le tourisme
est en train de reprendre et on voit ici
à la réunion les hôtels sont pleins mais
resteront son plein donc avec la
clientèle locale donc aujourd'hui c'est
développer tout ce qui dit j'ai très
ruraux développer les sentiers sentiers
littoraux et et départementaux donc sur
le territoire de saint leu de trois
bassins mais aussi de la réunion j'ai en
charge la gestion d des musées il ya du
musée de concernés chez nous
conservatoire littoral conservatoire
botanique des mascarins et le musée du
sel d'autant plus que l'on va livrer la
rénovation
le 1er octobre du musée du sel donc avec
une capacité de produire 100 tonnes de
sel donc sur pointe au sel est donc
aujourd'hui
gr coeur de travailler pour la réunion
dans cette délégation au niveau du
tourisme et au niveau du développement
rural
je me suis engagé e
être candidat au conseil des parents
content j'ai été élu donc aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est la collectivité qui se
retrouvent au plus près des réunionnais
combo social au niveau de l'économie
touristique au niveau des personnes
âgées au niveau de la petite enfance et
j'en passe et et d'autre beaucoup
d'actions sont mis en place pour
améliorer les conditions de vie des
réunionnais